una decena normal en Ucrania pero que
pocas veces se ven los medios de
comunicación nuestro permiso para
filmarlo es una excepción el ejército
recluta en las calles
estos hombres no pueden ser reclutados
pero le recordamos que como tienen 16
años tienen que registrarse en la
oficina de reclutamiento
los hombres menores de 27 años solo
pueden ser reclutados y ya realizaron el
servicio militar sin embargo todos
aquellos que tengan entre 27 y 60 años
pueden ser reclutados muchos están
exentos por razones médicas o
profesionales pero deben notificarlo al
centro de reclutamiento Ok entonces
mañana a las 9 a.m en la dirección que
se indica aquí el ejército debe tener
listas para saber con quién puede contar
Y con quién no
los muchachos vinieron tranquila y
amablemente no me detuvieron y me
llevaron por la fuerza como ha ocurrido
a veces en nuestra ciudad me entregaron
mis documentos educadamente a la Europea
Ese es el deber de todo ciudadano
pero muchos quieren evitar estas
patrullas a toda Costa Tan pronto como
entran al parque aparece un mensaje que
alerta sobre su presencia en el servicio
de mensajería Telegram decenas de miles
de ucranianos están suscritos a estos
canales que les avisan cuando una
patrulla opera en su zona miles incluso
pagan sobornos para evitar ser
reclutados uno de ellos aceptó hablar
con nosotros con la condición de
permanecer en el anonimato y no ser
localizado
el permiso me costó unos $7.000 dólares
es un certificado médico que declara que
no soy apto para el servicio militar
primero pagué luego fui a las clínicas
indicadas y al cabo de una semana recibí
mi documento
muchos de estos evasores manifiestan su
Patriotismo pero argumentan no querer
cumplir con el servicio militar por
razones económicas o familiares a veces
también admiten tener miedo a morir
hay rumores de que después de Solo dos o
tres semanas los envían a uno a un lugar
cerca de bahamut todos podemos morir
allá y si uno no tiene experiencia eso
sucederá muy pronto
según el viceministro de defensa
ucraniano Rusia estaría detrás de estos
rumores
intentan obstaculizar nuestra campaña de
reclutamiento mediante operaciones
psicológicas
para lo que utilizan diversos
instrumentos Empezando por la
información falsa
historia este argumento no es lo
suficientemente convincente es bitlana y
georgie son parte de los muchos
veteranos heridos en combate que ahora
trabajan en centros de reclutamiento
detrás de este cartel Que invita a la
gente a alistarse en el ejército está la
estación de servicio en la que es bit
lana estaba repartiendo circulares de
reclutamiento cuando cayó un cohete
uno de los doctores dijo que yo no iba a
sobrevivir
Tan pronto como se recuperó de las
múltiples heridas en órganos vitales es
bitlana decidió Volver al servicio
desaprueba el comportamiento de quienes
intentan evadirlo
muchos lloran
muchos tienen miedo
y muchos ponen todo tipo de excusas
me siento a escucharlos
Jordi perdió su brazo en el frente de
gersón
mi herida asusta a la gente
piensan que podría pasarle a ellos
Aunque por otro lado cuando ven que
alguien que fue herido sigue sirviendo
también les motivó un poco
aquí en el centro de reclutamiento de
Nicolás iep donde deben presentarse los
soldados reclutados es bitlana está a
cargo de la base de datos de hecho como
se declaró la ley Marcial todos los
hombres en edad militar deberían
presentarse para un control médico y
para actualizar su estado civil
[Música]
en mi collife hay cierta reticencia a
unirse a las filas
Por supuesto que iría Pero sinceramente
por ahora no estoy listo
tendría que pensarlo
nunca he disparado un arma ni he tenido
una en mis manos no es que tenga miedo
pero sería raro
en la región de kiev los nuevos reclutas
ya están entrenando para la
contraofensiva
pensamos en eso todo el tiempo
trabajamos en las tácticas para atacar
las posiciones de nuestro enemigo
para recuperar nuestro territorio y
nuestro país
se alistó por voluntad propia pero
entiende a aquellos que se resisten a ir
la gente tiene todo tipo de problemas
voy a decirlo de esta manera si toca si
realmente necesitamos gente entonces
incluso aquellos que hoy no quieren hoy
servirán
millones de personas en Ucrania esperan
que esto no ocurra